I have been dealing with the
mice for up to a month now.
They've just been waking
me up and making me nervous
about getting holes in my gear.
I do not like mice.
So I named my [inaudible].
This is one I've killed five
or six on, something like that.
The first one in
Vancouver Island,
the one that I was catching a
lot of them on, I named Slayer.
This one is Slayer Number 2.
I thought that was a
good name, Slayer 2.
And this is the one
I just made that I
caught one on just today--
The Death Dealer.
Man, I can't tell you what a
nice night it was last night
not listening to them.
Believe me, I can sleep through.
But when they're just
boring into your skull,
it's just-- it's so
frustrating, man.
And last night, I woke
up, it was just silent.
I loved it.
Here comes the rain.
Ah, there was just
a mouse right there.
How many of these [bleep]
do I have to kill?
[bleep]
Damn it!
[bleep] this place.
Not [bleep] enjoying
myself anymore, man.
[bleep] damn it, ya
[bleep] little bastards.
I am not having fun anymore.
Just one more day.
You can do it.